Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going take a collection of photos
like these, and magically, create a video
where we can fly through these photos.
So, how is this even possible?
Especially that the input is only a handful
of photos.
Well, typically, we give it to a learning
algorithm and ask it to synthesize a photorealistic
video where we fly through the scene as we
please.
Of course, that sounds impossible.
Especially that some information is given
about the scene, but this is really not much.
And as you see, this is not impossible at
all - through the power of learning-based
techniques, this previous AI is already capable
of pulling off this amazing trick.
And today, I am going to show you that through
this incredible new paper, with a little expertise,
something like this can be done even at home,
on our own machines.
Why?
Because now, research scientists at Google
and Harvard also published their take on this
problem.
And they promise two fantastic improvements:
Improvement number one.
Unbounded scenes.
No more front-facing scene with a stationary
camera.
They say that now, we can rotate the camera
around the object, and their technique will
still work.
That is a huge deal…if it indeed works.
We will see.
You know what, hold on to your papers, and,
let’s see together right now.
Wow!
This does not look like an AI-made video out
of a bunch of photos.
This looks like reality!
My goodness.
And, of course, you are experienced Fellow
Scholars over there, so I bet you are immediately
interested in the fidelity of the geometry,
which truly is a sight to behold.
I am a light transport researcher by trade,
so I am additionally looking at the specular
highlights.
This is as close to reality as it gets.
The depth maps it produces, which describe
the distance of these objects from the camera,
and, they are also silky smooth.
Outstanding.
So, is this a one-off result, or is this a
robust technique that works on a variety of
scenes?
Well, I bet you know the answer by now.
But wait, we talked about two promises.
Promise number one was the unbounded scenes
with the moving camera.
What is promise number two?
Well, promise number two is free antialiasing.
Ooh boy!
This is a technique from computer graphics
that helps us overcome these jagged edges
that are usually present in lower resolution
images.
And, it really works so well, check out this
comparison against a previous work by the
name mip-NERF.
And it is just so much better, the new method
truly seems to be in a league of its own.
We get smoother lines.
And pretty much every material, and every
piece of the geometry comes out better.
And note that this previous method is not
some ancient technique.
No-no!
mip-NERF is a technique from just a year ago.
Bravo Google and Bravo Harvard!
And remember, all this comes from just a quick
camera scan.
And the rest of the details is learned and
filled in by an AI.
And this technique now truly has a remarkable
understanding of the world around us.
So, just using a commodity camera, walking
around a scene, and creating a digital video
game version of it?
Absolutely incredible.
Sign me up, right now!
So, what do you think?
What else could this be useful for?
What do you expect to happen a couple more
papers down the line?
Please let me know in the comments below.
I’d love to hear
your thoughts.
Thanks for watching and
for your generous support, and I'll see you
next time!